pesa tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
video sono fa vj oggi siamo tornati su
my little pony
non è vero siamo su un never ending
nightmares che suona più o meno come my
little pony sono un po più brutto va beh
l'ex cristo andando legadue sta cosa sta
succedendo se non ne fossi sono cascato
di non cosa diavolo è successo va beh
non possono fare giochi così e d'arme
l'impasto come se fossero roba cosa sta
succedendo perché pieno lib e ri di e
come ti sei permesso di chiudere gli
occhi di ota vabbè ora mi prendo anche
per il culo come andiamo avanti noi che
se ne fotte sta diventando quanto strano
questi tizi bombati che tentano di
stuprarmi però vabbè non ti mettere in
quella posizione 6 a rischio tanto più
vado avanti sto gioco più è pieno di
marionette quindi non sto capelli o
cazzo corri veloce ma voli sono a
braccio ma dirlo ma magari un po meno ma
wireless vuoi e ho capito zio che hai
bisogno di affetto tutti hanno bisogno
di affetto ma taci tu vai vai vai vai
che ci entro ciò fatta non mi ha visto
entrare
meno male che [ __ ] meno male che io
sono ancora più [ __ ] proprio c'è una
gara che vi stupido né forse vinco io
ma il bello ragazzi che prima io ci
credevo anche quando sono uscito adesso
io ci credevo pure a dirgli riuscito a
schivarlo c'è un genio che poi
inquietantissimo c'è la faccia di un
bambino le gambe di brock lesnar ecc al
pene di rocco siffredi essa shakerare
bene i cocktail questo lo dedotto io
sono andato fuori dai [ __ ] perfetto
bye bye bye bye bye bye bye tirava no no
no no devi capire che non puoi far se
cagate perfetto computer
ascoltami non devi avere paura di il suo
gioco devi capire che sono io in grado
di difenderti quindi non c'è bisogno di
uscirne se esci abbiamo tutti e due nel
culo quindi evita di fare ste cagate ok
tonico una volta sola quanti cazzo ce ne
sono madonna di quella madonna di quella
madonna di quell uomo donna cioè non è
possibile ragazzino non ci sto credendo
mai nella vita cioè una roba veramente
ma veramente senza senso ci ascolta big
show il cazzo sei vai vai vai vai vai
vai picco io la royal rumble [ __ ]
sono andato per cagato addosso avuto
powered me che sono di attivare per
riuscire a superare su deficienza forse
ho capito
credo elio che capisco una cosa io ce ne
vuole lo so
torna di perfetto entra entra veloce del
secco capisce di essere stupido e muore
perfetto ragazzi ce l'abbiamo fatta
guardatevi due che si raccontano le
storie mentre sono chiuso nell'armadio
che pirla che vai di temi che ce n'è un
altro e tiro giù il calendario è
l'abbiamo fatta se scale che vanno di
sopra accendiamo un cero ragazzi non ci
posso credere ma seriamente ci sono
scale che non portano in cantina mio dio
che fa the gang bang bang bang a suor
susan e vabbè mi dispiace sorella ma non
è colpa mia
stiamo andando buongiorno zia scotta ti
dovresti avere un pò i denti ma che fai
oh cazzo cosa c'è alla fammi capire zio
sono stato 12 ore a scappare da
deficienti che si bombardano di steroidi
e poi tier coltelli da solo non ha
scritto becco in giro di schiaffi in
faccia ma non ha idea magari non averti
vi giuro
[Applauso]
ma quasi quasi io rimarrei a dormire
tranquillo cioè non stavo male ma
ascolta zia non puoi uscire dalle sbarre
la sinistra no è sporca la merda dove
sono dove sono prima di tutto erano
donne sta vedendo il mondo di patty la
si sa aperta un giovane che cos'è
outlast di caricare una roba atroce xvi
c'è dentro l'esterno che figo qualcosa
mi dice che se continua a farlo avrò una
brutta sorpresa ragazzi ma io continuerò
a farlo perché sono deficiente ragazzi
pronti e non è successo un cazzo
perfetto ma mi sono sbagliato io non ci
si può sbagliare alle volte sono umano
anch'io lo so che non ci credete ma sono
umana anch'io posso sbagliarmi è una
roba che mi succede ogni tanto è
raramente ma mi succederà ho sentito e
kakà temi cazzo di meno queste celle
perché a me che posso stare tutta la
vita con materasso che mette i materassi
da sentite io ho accoltellato mia se la
brutta gradito
dio mio perché mi hai abbandonato e non
lo so però io lo sapevo che passava il
deficiente ci avrei scommesso guarda che
è incredibile e lo sapevo pure un ultimo
schiaffi la famiglia finché non ti
diventa vergine la nonna ti ha creato
questo gioco chi l'ha fatto voglio
saperlo perché la cosa che mi fa più
incazzare di quando mi prendo un infarto
e quando me lo prendo e l'avevo già più
o meno capito però lo prendo uguale
[ __ ] perché lascia perde sapete
che forse ho capito o un'ipotesi su
questo gioco ragazzi credo che a sto
tizio di sia stata sterminata la
famiglia e che lui sia rinchiuso in
manicomio e non solo lui chi è stato a
sbattere la porta fatemi capire quindi
credo vi sia chiuso i manicomi e quindi
si sogna tutto perché la famiglia è
stata sterminata e 15 a questi incubi
credo che seba essere la trama del gioco
credo da come l'ha interpretata io e ha
forse è stato lui occhi della famiglia
addirittura perché dice sempre dio
perdona no alla cantina non regala
continuano uno di cui non vada socio la
rabbia nel pancreas giuro qualcuno ha
vomitato ragazzi avete sbloccato sul
pavimento
ma perché ci sono stanze tutte
fottutamente uguali perché ama miss ha
chiesto seguendo un tizio che sta
scappando pieno di sangue ovunque passo
volete favorire i cetrioli sottaceto
offro io il bello che so anche che sto
andando nella parte giusta che ci sono
una via il suo gioco almeno quello se
dovessi vagare per si cazzo di posti
senza avere un traguardo sarebbe
orribile
porca ladra [ __ ] ce la fai a correre
se vado a sinistra zio tv col non
non devi accasciarsi a terra ok 321
veloce ho vinto ho vinto sei stato
pienamente in grado di fare quello che
ti ho detto fratello ogni volta che che
che fai qualcosa sulla soddisfazione
nell'anima giuro sono i partiti dico
almeno si salari partitico entra veloce
niente mi deve saltare addosso mi deve
sputare il ketchup sul collo e normale
ragazzi sconta fratello ma siccome siamo
tutti i due in questo posto di merda non
ti andrebbe un po di schweppes solo io e
te
restivo madonna no no no no non mi ha
visto ho capito mi che allora aspetta
non devo correre perché c'è agli occhi
ma che merda per un ascolto zio esiste
chi compri il trucco te lo metti e sei
più bello te lo giuro bye bye bye bye
bye mama do 1.6 brutto entra e dio mio
dodici ore e mezza per fare sta ghiaiata
perfetto beve mi piace però giocare a
saddam e milan mi appaga riuscire a
capire e vedere che sono più bello di
certe persone soprattutto quel tizio di
prima in braccio posso prenderlo il
braccio mi serve posso darlo in testa
qualcuno da allora non me la crema beh
lasciamo soli i ragazzi ci sono
ovviamente le braccia capita di trovarlo
in gp3 ragazzino metto su subito.it
braccio trovato in un posto brutto
vendita sono 5 euro ma non vengo
consegnarmelo 6 in casa trovano la rete
delle scale che portano in alto li
mortacci delle scale che non è possibile
che noi dunque vada ci sono scale che
portano giù cribbio no no no no no no
scherzavo scherza sono fermo sono ferno
di home io sono fermo fermati il pisello
questa gente orribile ma brutta propongo
la fame no no sono fermo sono e allora
la madre a [ __ ] forte piano piano si
lo fa hanno tentato di palparmi ma non
ci sono riusciti a chi è che tenta di
pato armi ragazzi dove vi denuncio tutti
anche a te che sei brutto ragazzino ce
ne sono di sti tizi così ma voi se non
copia incolla mica almeno uno un po più
brutto un po più bello non cazzo proprio
tutti uguali il bello che no non ho mai
visto quanto cazzola alto questo salto
12 me casa è il michael jordan vai vai
vai cazzo è alto sto tizio cos'è
l'attacco dei giganti ragazzi versione
horror
oggi
non ha visto non ha visto ma visto ma
visto il suo no ma visto torri tutto nel
culo tutto madonna ho fatto ragazzi non
ci credo se i piatti sporchi da lavare
quasi quasi torno indietro e non c'ho
voglia una mano o la mano ragazzi i suoi
pezzi sto facendo il passo a abbiamo un
braccio una mano una green c'era
qualcos'altro che ho trovato che non mi
ricordo
l'abbraccio in mano dai ragazzi pian
piano facciamo tutto il puzzle e poi lo
vendiamo tutto insieme
ma ecco la testa a testa ho trovato a
testa che bella va bene e andiamo di qua
che mi sembra ancora figo non so come
mai il piede certo c'è veramente un
puzzle ragazzi cui qual è il senso però
di tutto questo spiega temo che cazzo no
no no no no no no no i vetri i vetri per
terra ma timori se la famiglia cazzola
ha visti vetri mortacci dei vetri pure
vai vai vai vai non mi toccare ti
denuncio bravo vede mine minacce
funziona ragazzi perfetto madonna posso
prendere una stampella e d'aria in testa
tipo ci voglia corri corri corri corri
veloce è perfetto avrà tirato attestato
sulla porta che sarà ricordata per tutta
la vita anche se non so quanto potrà
andare avanti a vivere quel tizio però
che tre scalo ovviamente che vanno in
basso madonna e proprio belle le scale
cioè neanche il sangue sul muro ti
invoglia proprio a scendere complimenti
ci penso che se avessi mai delle scale
davanti con del sangue sul muro che
ferita le armi braccio e venderlo su
ebay che fare questa che andare 18
queste cazzo sto trovando perché ci sono
le stanze piene di sangue adesso chi è
che al maestro ma pesante proprio wake
up
svegliati ma guarda di olmo mari
volentieri se non ci fosse il sangue per
terra porca ladra che sto ancora
dormendo la facciamoci una bella doccia
e ci svegliamo tutti bello la zona
doccia proprio di sangue perfetto
solleva come faccio a farmi la doccia
ragazzi spiegato la roba ancora ma basta
cazzo non mi ha preso non mi ha preso
avviato a testate contro il muro che
culo c'era un ammasso di corpi
bruttissimo che è roba orribile ho visto
ma li hai fatti tu così guarda che mi sa
che le braccia le gambe le ho trovate io
un po in giro se hai bisogno ti aiuta a
recuperarle 6 voglia esse non fate
quello che volete ma non cagato
cazzo a me devo schivarlo questo questo
affare tipo platform devo andare di qua
aspettare che passi fantastico chiaro
guarda credo che mia nonna la mattina
abbia più vitalità di te ma di 10 volte
proprio che è ok ok ok perfetto
grandissimo mio dio
le ore possiamo finirla queste istanze
che giuro talvolta stomaco basta vi
prego ragazzi basta
cos'è cos'è rega entrò solo perché non
capisco che cosa cazzo era ancora scala
e fotte sega basta che ce n'è ma non
posso più scendere merda c'è qualcuno
che mi segue non posso più scendere bene
adesso che volevo scendere in un posto
fantastico per cui mi spiega che cazzo
sto facendo dio mio
e tutto e tutto cosa poi c'è il continuo
di qua fanno il sequel è tutto e basta
ragazzi esso è tutto
le cose sono tutto corri corri corri se
l'ho presa né culo l'ho presa proprio
nel culo gaby cosa succede
moreno che le teche rai da qualche cosa
sta succedendo regala ho capito la
storia che avevo detto raga mi sa che
completamente giusta c'è pienamente io
sono andato dallo psichiatra perché ho
ucciso qualcuno e credo che lei mi sia
mia sorella quando realtà è la mia
psicologa perfetti sono impazzito ma beh
non c'è bisogno di essere così scontrosa
lurida [ __ ] patiti dancelli addosso
lettino però non lo faccio perché sono
un signore solo per questo comunque
ragazzi [ __ ] tutto date a cagare
concluso pili episodi ragazzi che è
stato alquanto strano ma veramente tanto
strano rientra ragazzi spero che vi do
vi sia piaciuto spero che non riusciate
a dormire anche poi scherzo da uno
scherzo scherzo no uno scherzo se il
video è piaciuto ma se il tracciato
mente mi piace anche a pagina di
facebook e co modalità tratta
descrizione sostenuti 16v di euro
possono vinto belle ragazze